hello and welcome to this video my name
is John Galt not my name maybe his name
is really John Galt I said something
that I should know is that some very
subtle historical reference that I'm not
getting on John Gould doesn't ring a
bell
okay maybe go for Banco reversed Banco
then III M
he just plays it like white dress with
colors reversed tempo should mean
something but poor I have no clue how
this is played I have analyzed this the
the colors reversed scenario but that is
a while ago
huh I don't like it absolutely not
I ultimately discarded this idea of
playing against the III line of the
Banco and now why it's like just like
like every move flat such as played
instead split second yeah you know okay
I mean I'm I'm always so rattled by this
that I'm blundering now D to win great
it's just great I never understand how
people can play that fast they're like
you know in a really rare variation that
nobody has a clue about really they play
insane moves and good moves there are
perfect moves whatever now I'm just
material down for nothing
how much two points I am two points for
absolutely nothing
okay if I play you gave to what what's
going on then
how do you save that you should I don't
see how
hmm did he track his own Bishop somehow
anyway I was two points down so it might
not be the easiest of things to win it
even though I mean my bishops are very
active and it's not easy at all for him
to get something going with his pawns
that is often a thing if you have a
couple of points for a piece if they are
not coordinated test their own tools and
both sides of the board and they cannot
form connected passed pawns quickly then
quite often quite often the pawns are
rather worthless and this is some
worthless worthless would be too strong
in this case but they are not worth all
that much
okay now him what is the thing I can
just take if I huh right
and asking him about the b7 pawn as well
[Music]
okay to check before the bishop on d6
makes rook b8 impossible
okay neide only three is actually pretty
good yeah it covers c4 and covers b5 and
cannot be attacked so it's quite okay
hey my part structure celebrating a
glorious comeback
that was weird I completely screwed
everything up and then he then when I
was winning all of a sudden
you cannot save cannot save this I
wanted to blunder everything again
fortunately it's difficult to screw this
up
and I played the most terrible opening
ever and by the way I was probably
confusing you with my commentary in the
opening so I was referring to to this
line in the bank home here in my bank
whole repertoire that I'm released about
two years ago and chasuble I ultimately
recommended that Blackshear to take here
and go for a more tactical way of
playing with Queen a5 and so on and I
and examined this line there's this this
Bishop e7 rook in three e6 and we here
take take Queen d6 is a critical
variation so keep that in mind and now
look at our game the difference is that
black is has not played this move it
makes a difference it must make a
difference but I have no clue what it is
I mean okay one thing I do understand if
I take on before in the other variation
there is a takes so that rook a 6b a6
becomes a possibility here after a
before I always has to take with the
piece of course but all in all that it's
not great yeah probably the whole line
for white is not the most fantastic
choice yeah okay 90 a3 is just it's just
bad I guess 95 should lead to some
compensation
it's believable now I've got some
activity for sure for the pawn a 91 was
just completely terrible
I was just blundering d2 and it's just
what it is
did not at all see that that was hanging
and I'm just just basically basically
lost night before it's just it's just a
really really big one yeah yeah from
minus two point something for white to
plus two point something so black is
completely winning here and he's
completely lost after blundering the
bishop
okay look FD one was stronger okay
because here he has this way to save
himself which wouldn't even be possible
here as the tanks yeah that makes a lot
of sense so it was a pretty awful game
on all accounts I also very late in a
very late stage I spotted that I'm
actually winning the piece yeah and here
White's
white is winning quite easily even
though if you just would do a pure count
yeah I would say okay it's got two
points but it's just like everything
hangs and he cannot cannot prevent me
from picking everything up it was just
completely completely lost yeah pretty
pretty M error mistake ruling game yeah
thanks a lot for watching